yes that is true you see that error
power I love you but that does not mean
that I love you because if all the I
love you that is coming to me they are
my girlfriend's then I think about 100
you know you might as well just stuck a
knife in my heart when I found that on
your phone I really you you have no idea
how much you hurt me
I'm hurt and I'm pissed off and I have
every right to be that would be like you
and putting my phone and you see that
I'm telling some dude that I love them
not cool
I've been cheated on before and there's
always that fear of my - are you gonna
cheat on me like the others be patient
I'm not - knew that she should be
patient that I would be doing wrong to
you all the time no the patient would do
it is a game don't here in Nigeria
despite all the bull drama between
husband and I I do love us men more than
life and I believe him when he says this
woman is nothing to him but I don't
think husband's ever had a woman ever
put him in his place
and I am that woman who has jumped up
and said hey you're not gonna mistreat
me I think he's better we understand
each other and we blend with each other
I don't know so you should blend with
the Nigerian culture but blend goodness
understand the life of your husband
throws your husband that is the only way
this relationship can last
[Music]